um not sound but print from mark murphy
the packers ceo christopher the closest
thing that the organization has to an
owner because it's a corporation
once every month or thereabouts mark
murphy does a q a column on the packers
official website and the latest one
dropped over the weekend now
this this is fascinating to me i'm going
to read the question
and then no please do the relevant part
of the answer yeah this is a question
from a guy named ken
dear mark you have done a great job
don't let the bastards drag you down
washington needs a name i suggest the
generals now there's nothing in the
question
that would in any way
remotely
point to the ongoing impasse with aaron
rodgers unless of course murphy believes
that one of the bastards dragging him
down is arrogant that's
yes
so what what murphy says and by the way
the the washington comments in there
because murphy played for the franchise
back in the day uh many many days ago
thanks ken said murphy the situation we
faced with aaron rodgers has divided our
fan base
the emails and letters i've received
reflect this fact as i wrote here last
month we remain committed to resolving
things with aaron and want him to be our
quarterback in 2021 and beyond we're
working to resolve the situation and
realize that the less both sides say
publicly
the better okay the less they say
publicly the better i agree
why in the house says the guy publicly
why in the hell are you saying this
publicly when the question that you're
responding to
doesn't even ask about aaron rodgers are
you kidding me
i i'm i don't i don't get it either it's
it's like they went in with a
preconceived notion of what they wanted
to get out there that that's really what
it is you know and uh just make up an
aaron rodgers question though this
question comes from paul seriously
that's right
what's up with aaron rodgers i mean who
who who's going to know that they made
up the question yeah exactly right the
whole thing this to me feels like the
middle finger back to aaron rodgers for
all of the pictures and videos of him in
hawaii for the first week of otas that's
what it feels like to me yeah i i get it
or at least another like just shot or
or notice of like hey look what you're
doing to the fans here and you know
we're caught you're causing a problem
with our fan base and those things like
almost playing to
you know a little bit of the
insecurities that you talk about a lot
of the times with rogers that he's
almost like hey look you divided us up
maybe he'll feel the pressure of this
comment you know i i thought of that
because i thought that's what you would
think of when i read this yesterday
that's really what i thought not that i
would have naturally come to that but
since i've worked with you so long i
actually thought of that because i was
like you know what mike
this might be part of that whole your
read on this situation which has been
damn good so far
it's been two weeks since rogers was on
espn for kenny maine's final sports
center and said i love my teammates i
love my coaches i love the fans
and it's an issue with the people
remember that the whole people
personally pay-per-people stuff we had a
little jingle from the office it was
great but this was all part of an effort
for him to avoid
alienating the fan base the way that
murphy is setting it up and i i take
issue with that based upon my own
experience and what i hear from people
early on
once the aaron rodgers stuff hit the fan
i was starting to sense that some fans
were were concerned but since then i
haven't gotten the sense that the fans
are aligning against him i think they're
taking a wait-and-see position in their
mind it doesn't matter until he doesn't
show up right for now it's just talk you
know they came to the conclusion that
rogers would have wanted them to come to
which uh it's all overblown it's all a
media creation don't believe any of it
for now
and uh what what what rogers
maybe didn't bank on is murphy being the
one to come out and say there is
polarization there is red state blue
state going on rogers doesn't want red
state blue state he doesn't want that he
wants everybody behind him
and i think that's one of the reasons
murphy said but he said you know there's
no way that this thing was just kind of
accidentally put out there by no way
this was the product of careful thought
deliberation agonizing over every word
we got to get it just right and let's
see how the people react to it and then
let's see how aaron reacts yeah i mean i
feel the same way you do as in the
you know there's the aaron rodgers
haters i think oh he's being a baby or
blah blah blah but they're not packers
fans i feel like the packers fan base
for the most part understands the
situation at least from
my take on things whether it's social
media or just watching the news or
they're they're reading local stuff
there to where yes i don't think there's
going to be any real blame until
you know someone makes some crazy
decision here or something is you know
something the crap hits the fan for lack
of a better phrase but like the
situation
is what it is because of mark murphy and
the green bay packers now and again
that's where i go back to this
divided the fan base sure whatever
phrase you want to do i i don't know but
again these are things where i want to
go
what did you expect to happen what did
you think was going to happen with your
fan base and a guy like aaron rodgers
who was still playing really good
football and all those things and that's
where
it's a weird situation altogether and i
think really in the end game i don't
know the more this goes on i just feel
like green bay's gonna look worse than
aaron rodgers
do you think that mark murphy doesn't
want rogers to show up
um
i think there's a
there might be a little bit of a
like yes and no i feel like i want to
say i feel like from maybe from the pr
standpoint and him not showing up it
could be one more time where they can
kind of point a finger and see like you
see he's a pain in the butt see we told
you he's not easy and all that but i
gotta think there's also another aspect
of them to go
wait if he doesn't show up and he
doesn't play and we do go eight and nine
or something like that whoa is our
butt's gonna be hot i mean people are
gonna want you know want us for dead the
fact that we had a super bowl team in
the mvp of football and he didn't show
up and now the team fell apart and oh
man the guy that we you know traded up
in the first round to get he just looked
okay and not great that's got to be in
the back of their mind too to where they
got to be at that moment going well i
hope he shows up because i'm just not
sure i'm ready for the reality of jordan
love and this football team quite yet
murphy separately was asked about jordan
love let me tell you what murphy had to
say about jordan love in the same column
it was a shame for jordan that the
pandemic impacted so much of his rookie
year although it wasn't a completely
wasted year we had no person in person
practices in the off season program and
no preseason game experience it's hard
to tell a lot in the offseason practices
both matt lafleur and offensive
coordinator nathaniel hackett have said
they like what they've seen from jordan
this offseason hackett said the biggest
difference this year is his confidence
in the system and that his decision
making timing and accuracy have all
improved it's obviously helped him to
get reps with the first team offense
this offseason twist the knife twist the
knife the preseason games this year will
be crucial in his development what also
will be crucial is whether he's the
starter or the backup in those preseason
games look i i look at it this way chris
they made the decision to trade up to
get jordan love and i i get it they
wanted justin jefferson he was gone they
wanted brandon nyuk they got leapfrogged
by the 49ers so they move up and get
jordan love they moved up to get jordan
love they saw something in jordan love
they believe in jordan love
and i think they'd very much like to
prove to the world that they got it
right yeah gordon locked yeah so but
he's telling you it's not ready yet
because of those excuses he made with
that and all of that that's well and and
and if we go eight and nine this year
this is why this is just set it up that
way you're right and and we're well
positioned for 20 22 i mean look at it
this way
if aaron rodgers is going to be gone
after this season
and i think he will be i think that that
they're going to trade him in in march
right
would you rather have jordan love
thrust into the starting role yeah for
the first time next year
would you rather have him
get the benefit of being the starter
this year because all the reps he gets
this year getting the game to slow down
this year they're going to be better
next year and there was always going to
be a transition yeah from rogers to love
you're right and and and maybe you just
say we'll take the 35 million dollars
we'll reapply that elsewhere
in the organization reinvest it again no
owner so no one's sucking away profit
you can take that money and reinvest it
and we don't have to worry about aaron
rodgers
winning a super bowl with the broncos or
the raiders or someone else
and he'll look like the jerk because he
sat out i really do think
that if mark murphy were to tell us the
honest-to-god truth right now he would
say i'd rather rogers not show we get 35
million jordan love gets a year to
develop and we trade aaron rodgers next
minute which we're gonna do whether he
shows up or not anyway i don't disagree
with anything you said except there's
just one aspect that is that to me
affects all of those things
you know and that is where exactly is
jordan loving his development and i
think that's why it's part of that quote
i think they're clueless
he's raw to begin with and then they
don't really know where he's at so
that's scary and i think like yeah it
like what you're talking about is good
to a certain degree but if it ends up
they got to find out i know they've got
to find out someday where they don't
want to do it at four four four and
before in 13 and him look really bad and
everything like that that's where they
got to be careful with this type of
situation and i'm sure that's where he's
making the comments about the pandemic
and we didn't get to do that i think in
the perfect world you're right he'd love
to be like man he played last lap
pre-sea uh pre-season he got the reps
last year screw you aaron rodgers we're
going with this guy go the hell sit out
of football i don't disagree with you in
that thought there but i think it's
about where
jordan love is in his progress and i
think that's probably where i think
aaron rodgers is also
knows he has power here i think he knows
jordan love ain't ready and they're not
going to have the guts to go to him
right now and that he is still the man
here in this situation so i think that's
where it's it's tough for green bay to
play that card i think
just me looking from the outside on the
you know on the outside looking in for a
guy like he is i do think he's raw
yes he didn't have the experience of
last year and all those type of things i
think of i'm in green bay and i'm just
the coach right i'm the coach and i want
the perfect world i'm going ooh i'd like
him to have one more year of you know
he can really be the backup quarterback
and get reps during the season i mean
the fact that he was not even dressed
for the football games last year
i don't know if everybody
what's that what'd you call that thing a
mega horn
that's a mega horn
okay it's going
[Music]
our first round quarterback we don't
trust him we don't trust him to be the
backup or the third stringer like that's
that's so that tells you how raw he is
that's really rare right mike i mean
again i'm just trying to think off the
top of my head you know first round
picks who don't even dress a whole year
in 2020
like you don't hear that story anymore
so that's to me where i think they got
to be a little careful
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports